et maintenant dans cette émission qui
s'appelle tout le monde en parle nous
passons à la rubrique personnes en part
[Musique]
ce soir là faire du meurtre au vatican
le 4 mai 1998 cédric tournay 23 ans vit
ce caporal de la garde suisse au vatican
a tué aloïs estermann le commandant de
l'armée du saint siège et sa femme
gladys avant de se suicider faux répond
la mère de cédric elle est là ce soir
voici muguette boda alors la version
officielle on la connaît donc cédric
tournay votre fils était garde son
supériorité aloïs estermann alors ce
aloïs estermann il faut savoir que si
celui qui avait sauvé la vie du pape
quand il avait été
victime de la tentative d'assassinât du
turc ali axa et le pape lui vouer
évidemment une reconnaissance éternelle
c'est son homme de confiance ils
l'emmenaient partout et ils
connaissaient ce aloïs estermann tous
les secrets évidemment du pape et tous
les scandales alors la version
officielle c'est que cédric se serait vu
refuser parce aloïs estermann une
décoration parce qu'il était rentré de
deux permissions 48 heures trop tard et
donc il aurait tué son supérieur
hiérarchique
il aurait tué la femme de ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques de la dce et il se serait
donné la mort c'est ça que vous
contestez en fait
j'ai comtesse plus que ça déjà les 48
heures je l'apprends dernièrement et non
ça n'a jamais été 48 heures 48 heures ça
serait beaucoup d'encre pour un
retard dans ses les retards qu'on a pu
lui donner ce d'une minute à 15,8 donc
la médaille
d'après deux ans quand on signe un
troisième année la médaille vient
d'office dans la lettre que vous avez
reçu du vatican on allait du saint siège
nous annonçant la mort de votre fille
s'était adressé un chat mort elle donc
alors que effectivement c'est sous ce
nom qu'ils étaient connus aussi mais
vous dites que l'employé jamais craqué
quand m'a remis une lettre soit disant
de cédric et qui m'auraient appelé un
chat mauvaise ouais alors que ça fait
dix ans que je m'appelais plus
chaleureux cette lettre vous les fait
expertiser par des graphologues et vous
êtes persuadé que c'est pas lui qui l'a
écrite
le papier était pas le papier à lettres
qu'ils utilisaient les supports non plus
ce support n'a jamais été vu dans la
correspondance avec six amis avec ses
amis c'est pas un support habituel
une enquête du vatican est très négative
pour votre votre fils ils disent qu'il
était homosexuel alors que vous vous
savez qu'il était fiancé avec une
dénommée valeria et aucun doute là
dessus non il n'y a vraiment aucun doute
là dessus tout ce qu'on a accusé
d'alcoologie
souci commun toxiques comme individu
caractériel c'est venu surtout pour
faire taire la maman donc à ce que
chaque fois que je disais non à quelque
chose derrière il arrive et ça leur
vernis est arrivé le kyste oui le christ
alors ils ont dit au vatican qu'il avait
un kyste gros comme un oeuf dans le
cerveau et c'est ça qui l'avait rendu
fou exactement ouais seulement
on me le dit enfin on me le dit même pas
parce que je la prends en même temps que
ceux qui lisent et je vous non parce que
jamais personnellement dit quoi que ce
soit je n'ai en tout pas la télé ou dans
les journaux
groupe comme un oeuf de pigeon
mais seulement neuf mois après alors
qu'il faut en octobre si donc tout de
suite le lendemain et là il aurait pu le
dire tout de suite je jouerai peut-être
compris mais neuf mois après c'était
vraiment
la dernière ressource qu'ils auraient
trouvé il ya un trou dans le crâne aussi
parce que c'est un trou de 7 mm non pas
de 9 mm 41 comme adil enquête du vatican
donc ça fait beaucoup de points
effectivement qui sont suspicieux il ya
beaucoup pointent la plus forte c'est
quand même l'imposition la tête la
sortie de la balle on pourra encore
regarder si c'était en matière du en
matière cul moi qui ai le cuir chevelu
donc ça c'est un peu un porte à faux
mais par contre la position de la de la
tête on ne peut pas se suicider dans
cette position ouais vous refusez donc
les conclusions de l'enquêté du vatican
je refuse l'anc est pour moi il y en a
pas une enquête puisque déjà trois
heures après sans témoins visuels on
peut dire que
il est mort donc on n'a plus un monde
est ce que j'aimerais dire c'est qu'on
ne permet pas à la maman
de de dire donnez moi des preuves
derniers mois quand même quelque chose
de tangible vous accusez la mort il peut
pas se défendre donc c'est quand même en
vivant à dire écoutez donnez moi
simplement assemblant de vingt 120 qui
tient la route et je dirais oui je
serais même contente au début que j'ai
commencé leur enquête je suis quand même
dit que j'arrêtais travailler mais pour
ça parce que j'ai vous dire quelque
chose qui jouait pas et je me disais moi
je les trouvais c'est lui qui l'a fait
alors on pouvait entamer une autre
procédure de deuil et puis dire il a
faim il a pété les plombs mais pour
péter les plombs moi je crois pas qu'on
a un peu pris un coup de folie
il est à ce moment là on a préparé il ya
une haine ils en choeur c'est vrai que
voulait partir oui satellite du brut et
la gare de suse noyade l'homme projet où
il y avait plein de projets ils vont
entrer donc lagarde était déjà derrière
ces vacances actives c'est pas son
travail on n'aurait pas donné le grade
de vis caporal qui représente en suisse
d'une c'est pas en france mais en suisse
ça représente le grade de sergent major
à un fou aussi qu'il avait passé tous
les examens pour entrer dans la gare du
vatican donc à l'époque il l'avait
trouvé parfaitement normal j'avais
engagé
laurent fau assassin et un suicidé alors
vous refusez les conclusions de cette
pseudo enquête comme vous dites vous
avez demandé au vatican un supplément d
enquête de lavaux que vos avocats l'ont
fait aussi ça a été refusé et maintenant
vous avez mis une requête devant la
justice suisse cois c'est à dire qu'au
départ j'ai quand j'ai vu comme ça se
passait j'ai une deux avocats romain et
quand nous avons qu'un roman on essayait
de rentrer dans la quête laura qui
collent leur a dit que l'enquêté en
cours donc il faudra voir à la fin de l'
enquête pour qu'ils puissent participer
mes avocats donc lire vos contacts et à
ce moment et vous écoutez le dossier
terminé en archives et vous pouvez plus
rien
si votre fils n'est pas coupable du
meurtre d'aloïs estermann et de sa femme
gladys
quel est pour vous l'hypothèse la plus
crédible aujourd'hui
donc il ya énormément parce que c'est un
milieu de se créer un milieu où c'est
qu'il ya des des envies on ne vendent
pas dans l'art hiérarchie sans marcher
sur l'autre monsieur est hermann
des gens disant qu'il a sauvé le saint
père je le conteste vous pouvez regarder
les images d archives il était en tout
cas son maître du chien père quand c'est
arrivé c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui sony
devant oui on va donner quand même une
image de sauveur donc pourquoi c'est
leur problème c'est pas mon problème on
a dit qu à loïs estermann était proche
de l'opus dei que sa femme était proche
de la franc maçonnerie est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils ont été éliminés peut-être
à cause d'une guerre des clans qui
sévirait au vatican comme dans tous les
lieux pouvoir toute façon si on fait
quelque chose quelqu'un c'est qu'il ya
des raisons
alors c'est vrai que
rentrant dans cette histoire quand j'ai
commencé je poussais pas prendre de
savoir tout ce que ça l'est j'ai perdu
énormément division
et je m'aperçois que quand on rate y a
rien derrière donc c'était une guerre de
pouvoir quand on rentre dans une guerre
de pouvoir avec le pouvoir l'argent
c'est une autre dimension c'est la
quatrième voire même peut-être s'il
existait ce hacking immense
vous croyez qu'un jour vous arriverez à
tirer cette affaire au clair
mon but est m au départ
j'avais confiance à la justice je dis
bien j'avais confiance pendant trois ans
j'ai gardé confiance à la justice
vaticane j'étais sûr qu'elle m'aiderait
je savais qu'elle était muselée bien
entendu mais j'avais confiance
et je me suis dit si ça ne marche pas ma
foi malheureusement je devrais faire
appel aux médias parce que les médias on
est critique on les aime on les aime pas
mais quand on sait quand même
l'intérieur solutions et 7 risque à
l'aube de ce millénaire c'est toujours
les médias qui doivent participer à la
justice alors que la justice fait pas
trop son travail mais c'est différent
marie noëlle vous êtes des questions à
poser un millier de boda le vatican est
pas directement dans l'union européenne
mais quand même rattachée à l'italie et
peut-être que de l'aide de la justice
suisse peut-être que la cour européenne
pourrait vous être l'ultime secours si
vous avez le sentiment que la vérité et
les enquêtes ne sont pas fait
ça évidemment sa part étrange quand on
entend comme ça
c'est en tout cas certainement une
grande douleur de perdre un enfant sans
avoir la certitude que ce qu'on lui mais
comme responsabilité n'est pas acquis ça
je crois que les procès en sorcellerie
sont toujours à bannir et encore plus au
vatican qu'ailleurs
franck c'est pas dangereux de s'attaquer
au vatican et bien au départ c'est ce
que tout le monde le disait ce que j'ai
dit faut essayer il faut que quelqu'un
essaye et l'approché il ya quatre ans
que je fais et je suis toujours vivante
alors où je devrais faire intentions
peut-être c'est quand tout sera fini
merci en tous les cas et puis on est
heureux
l'occasion de vous exprimer
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu